- [Karim] My name is Karim Akhnoukh.
I'm a senior solutions architect at AWS.
I've been with the company
since almost three years,
and I've worked with many
of the big manufacturers in Germany,
help them navigating the complexity
of deploying gen AI applications.
- [Mohamed] Okay, perfect.
My name is Mohamed Salah,
working as a solution architect at AWS,
looking after public
sector in the Middle East.
My job at AWS
is solving the similar problem.
Not Karim's (indistinct) problem,
but real manufacturer problems.
Picture this.
The same silence
inside your factory.
And you have machines stopped.
Your production line paused.
Everyone starts running around.
Every minute your products are not made,
your orders get delayed
and costs pile up.
Simply, this is what we are calling
this silence, unplanned downtime.
The top 500 manufacturers globally,
they are paying for this.
1.4 trillion US dollars due
to this unplanned downtime.
They are losing around 11%
of their revenues every year.
To make this more clear,
we are talking about
this is equivalent to the GDP
of the nation like Spain.
When we take a closer look about this,
we found four different challenges.
First is the data silos.
You have a production line,
and as part of this production line,
you have multiple machines.
Each machine has own alarms
and telemetry data,
but each machine has
its own separate database.
It will end up, you don't have
this kind of view, end-to-end view,
to understand exactly the relations
between the machine inside
the same production line.
The idea here is you have the data,
but the data is disconnected.
Second problem, which is a skill gap.
It's all about people.
For each manufacturer,
you have this senior expert
who can tell you, from the sound
of the mixer, there is a problem.
This is over-mixed dough.
Can tell you from the oven,
the right side of the
oven is much more heated
than the left side.
This kind of expertise,
if they are not there,
and you have a junior receive
this kind of a warning,
they will not be able to act.
And this is the second idea.
You have the knowledge,
but knowledge is not shared.
Third is the production delays,
and this is when this silence
feasible for everyone.
You have the junior, you
don't have those seniors.
You have the data, but the data scattered.
And they are not able to act
because they don't have the expertise,
they don't have the knowledge,
and that data is disconnected.
Last one is the operational disruption.
I know this is
very important for every factory
because most of the factories
are in remote areas.
When we are talking about the factory,
they are not having, most of the time,
stable internet connectivity,
and they don't have cloud access.
If you have a smart manufacturer
and this disconnected, under any reason,
this means
your manufacturer will be blind.
You will not have this kind
of data-driven decisions and insights.
That's why we thought
about simple solution.
Let's put all the data together,
in one single data link
inside AWS Outpost.
But when we did this,
we found a different challenge.
Each machine has
its own integration type.
I bought this machine from OEM X,
OEM Y, and OEM Z.
However, each OEM has
its own integration, even technology.
If we are talking about
modern IoT integration,
MQTT, or even LoRaWAN,
or we are talking about REST APIs
for POST HTTP and GET HTTP.
And most important part
about your manufacturer
is the documents.
Those kind of standard
operation procedure document,
manual documents, you can get it
using a legacy SFTP.
We thought about why not
to have this Outpost
underlying infrastructure
over EKS local cluster doing
this unified API deployment to absorb
those kind of different integrations?
And, accordingly, integrate this
with one consolidated data lake.
And then, to get the consumer
of those data lakes, will be an AI.
In our case, will be Bedrock.
And also to get much more insight
with a dashboard, using Amazon QuickSight.
This would be the result.
You have, on the left side,
you have a production line.
You understand everything.
You have the full details
and full understanding
about your production line.
And you can see the inspector
is telling you, you have cracked cookies.
The machine state is down
for five minutes.
Second problem
is the resiliency,
what we are calling always on.
Have to stay always on.
If you got disconnected,
Outpost disconnected from the cloud,
under any reason,
you will not be able to act
as a smart manufacturer anymore.
You will not be able to have
this kind of data-driven decisions.
You will not get automated
AI recommendations.
That's why we thought, why not
to add this intelligency at the edge
by deploying multiple
small language model?
We'll go through this later
as part of the sessions.
And to have two different features.
First,
to provide intelligence
for the operators, using text
and even voice, to chat with the data.
Second is to apply this
kind of an automation.
You are digesting your data,
and telemetry data every five minutes,
understanding the insights,
getting recommendations.
And if you feel this recommendations
require a notification,
notify the operator
with the required actions.
- [Karim] So before we jump
into the coding session,
which I know you're so much
looking forward by now,
please allow me two more minutes
to explain the big picture
so you understand how
the end-to-end workflow looks like.
We imagine having a cookie
factory which produces
the best-in-class cookies here in Vegas.
And for simplicity,
this cookie factory
has three big machines,
which are the cookie former,
followed by the freezer tunnel,
and lastly, the cookie inspector.
Now imagine the situation
when the cookie inspector,
which does the visual quality inspection,
detects a cookie which is cracked,
misshapen, or a cookie
with some air pockets.
Then we have our agentic
AI application running
inside AWS Outpost for the
always-on connectivity thing.
This agentic AI application has access
to different data sources,
including the machine manuals,
the standard operating procedures,
and real-time telemetry data and alarms.
And then operators inside
the production site
can chat or voice chat with the agent
to understand what is
the underlying problem.
And then it can finally instruct the agent
to itself take some actions
to correct the problem
inside the production site.
And, finally, we move from the state
where we had a cracked cookie
to a state where we are
producing delicious cookies
and everyone is happy again.
But you know what the problem is
with what I'm showing here?
I wish that the solution was as simple
as plugging in the icon of AWS Outpost.
Under the hood, there is a little bit
of a more complex architecture.
So on the right-hand side,
we have the pipeline for data preparation
and model fine tuning,
which we'll go into very details
at the rest of the session.
And on the left-hand side, we have
our agentic AI application
deployed on AWS Outpost.
And then we have different
specialized small language models.
We have GPT OSS model,
which will be the routing model
to navigate the different
tasks from the users
to the different tools.
We have the fine-tuned Llama
3.2 billion parameter model,
which will be specialized
into the RAG application.
And we finally have the SmolVLM
for visual quality inspection.
For sake of time,
we will not be implementing the SmolVLM,
but we will go through every other details
of the implementations.
So let's code.
I switch one.
Okay, so I hope you are seeing my screen.
You do? All right.
So I will start with setting up
the infrastructure deployment.
And I will be mimicking this
with a couple of EC2 machines.
I will be mimicking the
AWS Outpost environment
with couple of EC2 machines.
So let me navigate
to the first method here that we have,
which is the _create_ec2_instance.
And here, as you can see,
I'm using the g4dn.xlarge instance,
which is relatively small,
but capable instance.
It can be capable of running
a small language model.
I'm selecting a specific AMI,
which is the Nvidia one.
And then I'm creating
some security groups,
some VPCs, some IM role,
and so on, so forth.
But the most important
part that I would like
to stress on here and grab your attention
is this part, the user data script
which will be uploaded
to the EC2 instances,
because this is the one
that will be installing
the actual dependencies that is needed
to run the agentic AI application.
So if we take a look at, for example,
this EC2 machine, the user data script
of this EC2 machine, you will find
that it's 148 lines.
So it's not very realistic
to go through this line by line.
But, instead, what I would like to do
is I would like to use here your brains
to brainstorm together
what should be the dependencies
that should be added
to this EC2 machine.
So please take a moment, scan the QR code,
and think as if you are
deploying this application,
what dependencies do you need
on the EC2 machine in order
to host an AI agent
and a small language model,
which is that router small language model?
Please think about it, and in a moment,
I will be showing some results.
- [Mohamed] Karim?
This one. Okay.
- [Karim] Okay, so,
we are still collecting the votes.
So you guys almost nailed it, right?
Yeah, so, of course,
we need the agent code.
That goes without saying.
We need Docker runtime
because we will use Docker
to pull the container of Ollama,
which will be our software for hosting
the small language model.
We don't need the fine-tuned model
for this specific EC2 machine
because we are having another EC2 machine
where we will be deploying
the fine-tuned model.
We need the Nvidia Toolkit
for the CUDA software.
We need a custom Python version, indeed,
because the SDK that we will be using
for installing the AI agent is Strands,
and Strands works with a
minimum Python version of 3.10.
And the default Python
version in the G4dn instance
is Python 3.9, which
why we need to install
a custom Python version.
And the one who said Ollama,
that's actually correct
because we will be running
Ollama as a Docker container.
Okay, so that was for
the first EC2 machine,
for running the agent.
Now, please, again,
scan the QR code
and think what the dependencies do we need
for the EC2 machine
that will hold that
fine-tuned EC2 instance,
the fine-tuned small language model?
Okay, so let me view
the results.
Yes, yes, yes.
We need Docker, we need
the fine-tuned model.
In that case, we don't need
a custom Python version anymore
because it works with the default version
of the g4dn.xlarge.
That was a tricky question.
We don't need the agent code.
That was deployed on
the first EC2 machine.
And we need Ollama
and we need the SLM, of course.
Okay, so I'm happy that we
well-brainstormed the dependencies.
Now, after we write
the user data script, like I said,
we create a VPC, we
create security groups,
we create an IM role with access to S3.
And when we are happy with that,
we need to deploy our application.
Okay.
- [Mohamed] Perfect.
Now we have infrastructure
starting to deploy.
Karim will debug for
sure what is going on.
But during this time,
let give you some tips and tricks,
how to do a deployment
for a small language
model over AWS Outpost.
We'll take a closer look here.
The GPU instance that we have over Outpost
is the G4dn.
And to deploy any model,
you have to consider two things.
First is the hardware constraint.
We are talking about g4dn.12xlarge,
which is four T4 Nvidia instance,
each one of them powered by 16 giga
of memory, gigabytes of memory.
At the same time,
and this is the second consideration,
is the model itself.
We are taking an example
of a open AI model OSS,
around 20 billion parameters.
But here, I mentioned different parameter,
which is very important
to consider while doing
a deployment over the Outpost.
One of them is if this is a mixture
of expert or not?
How many layers
and the active parameters per token?
Now, let's focus on the first strategy
to do the deployment, is a quantization.
Quantization, in a nutshell,
is reducing
the number of bits
presenting your weights
in order to reduce the memory footprint.
This model, trained by using
the precision of FP16.
This is a base model.
However, we can have another quantization,
which is MXFP4.
We are talking about how
to present each weight.
to present each parameter.
And instead of presenting each weight
with 16 bit, you can
present the same weight
with four bits.
This will make a significance reduction
in the memory footprint.
Instead of having the full position,
which is a base model, 40 gigabyte,
you can get only 13 gigabytes.
But everything came with a cost.
The cost here is accuracy.
For the baseline,
you don't have an accuracy impact.
However, for mixture of MXFP4,
because you are going to reduce the number
of bits presenting your weights,
you will have 1 to 2% accuracy impact.
This means that you can save
65% of your memory,
trading this by 1
to 2% of accuracy loss.
By doing this, you will have,
the full model can be deployed
with the 13 gigabyte in your memory.
Do you remember the hardware constraint?
We have 16 gigabytes.
Now you can have
the full model deployed inside GPU.
One of the deployment strategy
is to deploy the full model in one GPU,
as you can see here.
We are going to replicate the same model
across the GPUs.
And the significance of doing this
is to have
latency-sensitive workload implementing
by doing parallel processing
for multiple clients at the same time.
Your application will not have any kind
of a tolerance for the latency.
You are going to do processing
in a separate GPU for each client.
Second strategy is
this.
You have one single model,
weights shorted across GPUs,
where for each GPU, you
will have 3.2 gigabytes
for the model weights.
And the remaining will
be for the KV cache.
KV cache is simply,
this is how to cache the tokens
as part of your session in order not
to let the model recalculate the token
every time, generating new content.
If you have a larger KV cache, this means
that you can get
large number of users,
and the same time, you can get
a larger context window.
And this is important for your session.
Let me show you
the foundational part of this.
We started to, with the architecture,
high-level architecture,
where we can start with
the data preparation.
Let me show you something
with the data here.
As you can see, those
are the data sources.
You have different types of data source.
You have CSV files, you have text files,
and you have PDF files.
This is a normal data source,
how it look like.
You have different files,
you have a different format
because you have, in your production line,
you have different OEMs,
and each one of them has its own structure
to do this.
What we need to do is
to fine tune the model,
but what is the objective
of fine tuning the model?
The objective here is to give an assistant
for your operators.
This assistant will help your operator
to have detailed, instructed steps
considering the severity of each problem,
considering the compliance,
considering the safety,
and so on and so forth.
The most important part
is to let the model
understand the skills needed
and let the model talk
with the same tone needed.
That's why we decided to use
a fine-tuned model,
using instructed fine tuning.
Let's start with what exactly
happening under the hood.
I will show you here, in the right side,
as you can see, this is a data pipeline
where you can read the
different documents,
PDF file, text file, and document files.
And then you can invoke a larger model
in order to generate structured data
to fine tune your model.
The most important question here,
why to not through the
data to the model directly
to fine tune the model?
The answer, simply,
is if you are throwing
your data right away
at your model, you are training
a hallucination machine.
The important part here,
reading the document,
invoking the model
to return structured data,
accordingly validate those data,
and then you are happy
to have full structure documents
in order to fine tune the model.
Let's start with
running this.
As you can see,
the pipeline start reading this,
and at the same time,
start invoking the Bedrock
to generate questions and answers.
Why to generate the questions and answers?
In order to have an instructed dataset
in order to fine tune your model.
Let me show you something here.
This is the data preparation class
that we are using to invoke the model.
As you can see, here,
we are using this model
to generate the structured data.
And the most important part of this is,
let me show you something very important,
is the converse API.
As you can see here,
we are using the converse API.
Converse API is giving you the flexibility
of changing any model,
at any point of time,
because it's using, for different models,
same API signature.
At the same time, and
the most important part,
is the inference configurations.
If you are configuring the maximum number
of tokens correctly, you will be able
to get your answer correctly,
without having any kind
of data split or something.
The most important part here
is the system prompt.
This is an instructed prompt
with only one shot.
I'm giving the model a clear
and detailed instruction to generate
the realistic information,
to include the severity
to answer the safety questions correctly
and include the needed information.
By doing this,
you will be able to have
a full dataset
with your structure,
with your structured data.
Second, and this is very important,
why do we need to trust the LLM?
Maybe the LLM itself will hallucinate.
In this case, if your
LLM is hallucinating,
you have to apply what we are calling
deterministic validations.
Yes, the LLM generated the content,
but if this content is correct,
if this is a right question and answer,
if this is following
what the standard operation
procedure is telling you,
if this is following
even the needed structure
for your response in adjacent way,
why this is important?
Because, again, we need to make sure
that we are not having
a single record in your structured data
for fine tuning the model.
Second is shorting.
If you are starting to short your data,
you have to short your
data in a smart way.
If you have a very long paragraph,
you cannot cut the paragraph in between.
If you have a large section,
you have to make sure that this section
is split in a correct way.
You cannot cut or split
a sentence in the middle.
Why this is important?
Again, same objective,
structured data implemented correctly.
As we can see on the right side,
the job is done.
And we have generated Q and A, done,
validation, done.
And as you can see, we
have some statistics here.
We have 50 pair of questions
and the answers requested, 45 generated,
and we have five rejected.
We can check here the output file.
And from the output file,
you can see this is rejected
because of the frozen
belt misalignment section.
This is the content,
and this is the critical
information which is wrong.
Why?
Because the model itself
or the pipeline itself
is doing this validations
across the needed structure
and across even the data inside the SOP.
Accordingly, now we uploaded the data
inside S3 in order to start
fine tuning the model.
I'm not sure if you
are familiar with this.
This is AWS SageMaker AI Studio,
where you can start to
fine tune the model.
If you go on the left,
you can see this is Jumpstart.
Inside the Jumpstart,
you can select the model.
Here, the model family is Meta.
This is a model family.
Perfect.
Llama 3.2
billion instruct.
This is our model.
Here, you will find the
three different options,
either to evaluate, deploy, and train.
In our case, we are
going to train the model.
I'm going to select training the model.
After selecting the model,
you have to select the dataset
we did as part of the data preparation
for the dataset.
Here is the dataset.
Here is the data we just uploaded.
We select the data.
And then we need, this
fine tuning will be,
there is an output of this fine tuning
or updated weights of your model
based on your dataset.
You are going to set the S3 bucket
to get your updated model.
Accordingly, you can go through this.
I think it is normal
to have five (indistinct).
And this is very important.
This is AWS recommended recipe
to do the fine tuning,
using this G5 instance.
If you want to select a
different instance, it is fine.
This is fully flexible,
but this is what we are
recommending as part
of fine tuning the model.
Accordingly, we are going to use
the same identity access management,
same VPC, same encryption keys.
And then we'll submit the model.
We have to agree on those things.
And then job started
to do the fine tuning for the model.
- [Karim] Okay, so now
I bet that many of you
is asking themselves one question,
which is, in my opinion,
very valid if you are asking it.
And the question is,
why are you guys doing
this model fine tuning
and data preparation
when you will anyways be using
a RAG task in the edge?
Maybe you are asking yourself
if we just added this
piece of architecture
in order to make our architecture look
a little bit more fancy.
Well, while we may love doing so,
but, in fact, we have done
extensive experimentation
in order to prove that this approach
is, indeed, valid.
And in order to prove that,
we have used the technique
which is called LLM-as-a-judge evaluation.
And let me show you how
this technique works.
(indistinct)
- Hmm?
- [Karim] I'm gonna try something.
Okay, please allow me a moment.
(Mohamed speaks indistinctly)
- [Karim] Yeah, for some reason,
the aspect ratio is not working well.
- [Mohamed] Put a different browser.
(mumbles)
- [Karim] Okay, so let me explain
how LLM-as-a-judge evaluation works.
I had some fancy animation, but, anyways.
So we have our fine-tuned model
and we have our base model,
that Llama-based model
that is produced by Meta,
and we want to compare the performance
of both models on direct task.
So how it works, at the very first step,
what we provide to both
models is the question
and the context from the test dataset.
And we ask both models
to generate an answer
based on those question and context
because usually this is how
we do it in RAG applications.
And then, as a next step,
we have our three
LLM-as-a-judge evaluators.
We have Claude 4.5 Sonnet,
we have Claude 4.5 Haiku,
and we have Amazon Nova Pro as judges.
And we pass to each
of those three judges
five different inputs.
We pass the question and the context
from the test dataset
that Salah has generated.
We pass the answer from
the fine-tuned model
from the previous step that I just showed,
and we pass the answer from the base model
based on the question and context.
And, finally, we also pass
the ground truth answer
from the test dataset.
And we ask each of those three models
to evaluate the result,
the result generated
from the fine-tuned model
and the base model,
based on three evaluation criteria,
which are, number one,
accuracy, which measures
how well the result from
the fine-tuned model
and the base model agrees
with the ground truth answer
from the test dataset.
Number two evaluation criteria
is the completeness, which
measures how well the answer
is addressing all the different aspects
of the question.
And number three evaluation criteria
is the relevance, which is, in my opinion,
the most important metric
in the RAG application
because this one measures
how well the answer
is following the context given to it,
because this is how RAG works.
And then we ask the three judges
to evaluate the performance
of the base model and
the fine-tuned model.
And here we have the results
of our LLM-as-a-judge evaluation.
In my opinion, this is
really great results
because this shows that
the different evaluators,
this different evaluator models,
shows that the fine-tuned
model is outperforming
the base model in the RAG task
for all the dataset aggregated
for all the three different
evaluator criteria.
So, for example, Claude 4.5 Haiku says
that the fine-tuned model is outperforming
the base model by 17%.
And Claude 4.5 Sonnet says
that the fine-tuned model
is outperforming by 15%.
And Nova Pro says it outperforms
the base model by 10%.
So, on average,
we have 14 percentage point improvements
for adding the fine-tuned
model on the RAG application
for our agentic AI application.
So now let me quickly recap
before jumping to the next step.
We started with deploying
the infrastructure
to our EC2 machines
in order to replicate or mimic
the environment of AWS Outpost
to have our agentic AI application.
Then Salah thankfully showed us how
to prepare the data, and fine tuned
a small language model for the RAG task.
And I just showed you how important
this is in our architecture.
Now we need to put this together
into an agentic AI application
that runs on the edge on AWS Outpost.
And this agentic AI
application will have access
to direct tool
and also the telemetry data tool.
So let's start doing that.
Okay, as you can see,
that our two EC2 machines are up
and running now, the
factory agent instance
and the fine-tuned small
language model instance.
So what I would like to do
is to log in
to the factory agent instance.
So I would use Kiro?? for that.
I installed a plugin for remote SSH.
I connect to the host.
And now it's opening an SSH session
inside the EC2 machine,
which we instantiated at the beginning.
So now we are in the EC2 machine.
I need to go inside
the factory agent directory,
which I copied in my user data script.
I zoom in a little bit.
Hmm.
Zoom in is not working.
- Oh-
- During this time-
- [Karim] Now I get the problem. (laughs)
- [Mohamed] Explain
something very important.
We used two different approaches here.
We used fine-tuned model,
and the same time, we used RAG.
Anyone have an impression why we did both?
Because most of the time,
you are using one of them.
Any answers?
Huh?
- [Audience Member] The
information that it's showing
on the right database
(speaks faintly) updated
in the future (speaks faintly)
fine-tuned model where
it can support that.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- [Mohamed] And let me
dive deep into this.
The most important part here
is to have the knowledge
about your document
and the skills needed.
To fine tune the model
as you are gaining the skill needed,
you are setting the tone of your agent
to respond correctly.
By having a RAG, you are retrieving
up-to-date information
from your knowledge base.
That's why we combine both
to achieve this LLM-as-a-judge
evaluation results.
We are talking about 15% increase
from the base model.
- [Karim] Cool.
So now, as Salah is
talking about the RAG tool,
I would like to start with showing you how
to develop that RAG tool
that I will be using
for my agent application.
And I pre-created this class,
which is called RAG retriever.
Previously, I also, in my environment,
I pre-ingested the
documents inside Chroma DB
as a vector restore.
And I created a very simple method,
which is a search method,
that you can provide it with a query
and the number of results,
and then it uses this query
to look up the information
inside the vector store,
and retrieves the most
relevant information
from within your vector store.
And then I use that tool decorator
from Strands SDK in order to have
this search documents method.
And here, I'm providing some docstring
which will be used by the
agent to understand what
this tool is doing
and how it can actually be used.
And then, as you can see,
we are iterating over the results
of the retrieval
from the vector store,
and we are printing
them in a noise format.
So this is a tool for RAG retrieval,
augmented and generation.
Do you think, in this implementation here,
anything is missing here?
Again, we have retrieval,
augmented, and generation.
Anything you see missing in
this tool implementation?
- [Mohamed] A major thing.
(Karim and Mohamed laugh)
- [Karim] Okay, just to save your time,
we have the G missing,
the generation missing.
If you remember, the model
that Salah spent some time fine tuning,
we're not using that model here, right?
And what I would like to
show you is how to use
that model in order to
enhance the results,
like I showed in the
LLM-as-a-judge evaluation.
So what I will do,
we will be instantiating Ollama client
using the IP address of the machine
which has the fine-tuned model
with the port that opens up
the Ollama connection.
And then I need to just copy
and paste couple of code parts.
I will just paste it here.
Yeah.
And then I change this to response.
Okay, so now we have
our RAG tool complete,
at least in my eyes.
We have the retrieval part
and we have the generation part,
asking Ollama to invoke the endpoint
of our fine-tuned model,
passing with the query and the result.
So this was the first tool,
and this tool was to retrieve
the standard operating procedures
and the manuals from
the different machines
inside your production line.
Now, the second tool
is that telemetry tool.
And this telemetry tool is to retrieve
real-time telemetry data and alarms
from your machines inside
your production line.
And I have marked this real-time data
by a very simple CSV file,
as you can see.
I'm not sure if you're seeing.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
As you can see, the CSV
file has a device name,
the sensor type of that
specific device, the reading,
and the timestamp for that reading.
And we have two devices.
If you remember from my first slide,
we have freezer tunnel machine
and the cookie former machine.
And for each of those two devices,
we have two different sensors,
the temperature and the speed.
And then we have the reading
for those different sensors.
And, finally, the timestamp
at that specific reading.
So for the telemetry tool,
I also pre-created a class,
which is the telemetry reader
that reads this CSV file.
And then I also created
another helper method,
which converts this CSV into a timeframe.
And we pass to this method three things,
the device name that we want to look for,
that we want to look the telemetry for.
The current time where we are standing.
And the number of minutes back in time
where we want to look at.
So, for example, if we want to look
at the telemetry data for
the last five minutes,
we set the minutes back here to five.
And here, if we, for example, provided
as an input the device name corresponds
to freezer tunnel, this is how
the output can look like.
So the freezer tunnel
has temperature and speed sensors,
and those are the readings
for the different timestamps.
Now I want to create a Strands tool
out of that one.
So let me create it as we go.
If you remember, I would
use that tool decorator.
I would create a method called
get_telemetry
_data.
And for that method, I need a device name,
which is of type string.
And I need minutes back,
which is of type integer.
And the return should be here,
a formatted string.
Again, for any tool, we need
to have a well-structured docstring.
So I will be copying the
docstring from my notes here.
And then we need to code the tool.
So this method here instantiates
the class telemetry reader.
We need to have it.
get_telemetry_reader.
And in order to call the method
which I showed you before,
which is this one here,
we need the device name,
which is passed as an input.
We need the minutes back, which
is also passed as an input.
And we need the current time string.
Luckily enough, Strands
has its own implementation
of current time, so we
will be using that one.
current_time_str
= current_time_ class from Strands.
And, finally, now we
need to call the method
that I just showed you,
data frame =
tel_reader.
Get_device_sensors_in_timeframe.
And we passed with the device name
that we have as an input.
We passed with the current time string
and we passed
with the minutes back.
And now we just need to formulate
our results in a nice F string,
Readings for device,
for the last
minutes:
And then we just need to
concatenate the results
that we get from the method,
result +=
json.dumps.
And then we have the data frame,
and we set the indentation to two.
And, finally, we return the results.
Cool.
So as any good software engineer,
I wrote a tool, I just need to test it.
Let me do that very quickly, in order
for the application to work at the end.
get_telemetry_data.
And we need to have one device
from our CSV file,
which is, for example, the freezer tunnel
for the last five minutes.
Okay, yeah.
I always do this problem.
It should be only return result,
and now it works.
So now you can see
that we have our readings
for the freezer tunnel
for the last five minutes
structured in a nice JSON format.
So the final thing that
I would like to add here
is a very simple tool inside
this telemetry tool, which is a tool
that can be used as a
lookup for the agent,
to understand which devices
that it has access to.
Think about the situation here.
For example, I type freezer_tunnel,
which is the name that I just copied
and pasted as-is from the CSV file.
In real-life scenario,
users don't know how
the exact name is written
inside your database.
So we need to have some sort of a lookup
so that if, for example,
the user had a typo
or type it without the underscore
or had a capital, small
letter or so on, so forth,
this should work.
So let me just copy and paste
the last tool, list_available_devices.
And that should be it.
And now the last fun part,
which is the agent
which puts all those things together.
And so I pre-created this class,
which is called FactoryAgent.
It uses the GPT OSS model, the edge model
that I deployed at the
beginning of the session.
And here, it uses
this big system prompt.
I would like to walk
you through the prompt
and how I structured it
because it might be relevant to you.
So the first thing that I pass
to the prompt is some orientation
to how the tools look like,
what tools does it has access to.
And the second thing is some scenarios,
some possible scenarios and examples
of users' interaction.
And based on those user
interactions, what tools
that the agent should be
using one after the other.
So it's some sort of a
few short prompting here.
Right.
And then we have the system
prompt, we have the model,
and we have the tools I
imported from the class.
We instantiate the Strands
agent, and we are good to go.
Finally, we need to test our agent
and see how the result looks like.
Before the session, I
asked my best friend Kiro
to create a nice UI
that I will be using to test my agent.
So I will be just invoking
this agent, this UI.
Yep. And here we have our UI.
So now, since we have our agent,
I would like you to put yourself
into the shoes of the operator
inside the cookie factory.
Remember, my first slide.
When the visual inspector has detected
a problem inside the cookie.
Now you are a junior operator inside
this cookie factory
and you want to understand
what is the problem.
You know that the visual
quality inspection
has two devices in front of
it, which is the freezer tunnel
and the cookie former machine.
So as a junior operator now,
what I would do is ask
a very simple question, debug
freezer tunnel.
That's a very simple,
but it's a powerful enough prompt
in order for the agent to understand
or try to resonate what is wrong
with this freezer tunnel.
And as you can see,
it used the listing devices
because I didn't use the 100% correct name
of the device inside my CSV file.
It used the get telemetry
data tool that I just coded
and it used the search documentations tool
that we also have written for the RAG.
Let's see why that.
And as you can see in the results,
I will make it bigger in a second,
what it did is it retrieved
the telemetry data,
and it compared the telemetry data
with the correct results
from the documentations
to see if those measurements
make sense or not.
And in our case, it detected
that the temperature is
not in the correct range.
And here, it also suggested
some follow-up actions in order
to debug this machine
in order to restore it
to the operating state.
- [Mohamed] Okay, perfect.
This is what happens when
you have a factory start listening.
Everyone and everything
inside your factory
are now talking with the same language,
which means machines, IoT sensors,
systems, are fully integrated together.
Where you can have a AI system
that can give you, gives
you different types
of recommendations, explanations,
insights about your factory.
The important part here,
and this is a key take-away,
is we connected the operations
by having a full deployment
over Outpost EKS local cluster.
In case of any disconnection,
you still have access
to your control plane,
you still have access to your data plane,
and you can manage your
infrastructure completely
in case of any disruption.
Second is deploying
a small language model at the edge,
which makes this kind of intelligence
real-time intelligence.
You understanding what exactly
you are deploying the agents,
getting the insights, and then giving
a recommendation on the fly.
Third, and this is very important part,
is you are still generating
more data every day,
and you have to stay continuously learning
and continuously understanding
because the data is your gold.
Once you got this data,
update your model,
trigger the pipeline again,
and fine tune the model.
I encourage you to scan
those three QR codes
to do the full end-to-end deployment
of agentic AI, a small language model
at the edge.
Okay, now it's your turn
to start with the one single process.
Get some data, start to understand
your manufacturing production line
in a more detailed way.
Start small, fail fast,
understand your data,
structure the data in a
correct and proper way,
and then fine tune the model.
Get the fine-tuned model,
speak your language,
generating the correct information,
and then doing the deployment
on the edge over the Outpost.
Thank you, and it was
really a pleasure having you
as part of this session.
And I encourage you to take the survey
and give us the (indistinct).
Thank you. Thank you.
(audience applauds)